[Musique]
dans le sud de new delhi tg choir sont
d'où un trentenaire gay indien se
prépare pour faire la fête comme le
reste de la communauté lgbt il savoure
une liberté acquise il ya quatre ans
après la dépénalisation de
l'homosexualité
sans craindre d'exprimer son identité en
public
j'ai fait mon coming out il ya 14 ans je
devais me comporter comme un homme
parlait comme un homme discutait comme
un homme marcher comme un homme alors
qu'aujourd'hui je peux faire ce que je
veux aller où je veux ainsi les gens ne
l'acceptent pas c'est là problème
en septembre 2018 la cour suprême
indienne a abrogé l'article 377 du code
pénal une loi datant de l'empiré
britannique y criminaliser les rapports
entre personnes de même sexe les
policiers pouvaient l'utiliser pour les
placer en garde à vue à delhi comme dans
d'autres grandes villes du pays les
lieux lgbt se sont multipliés on y fait
la fête comme partout ailleurs sans
inquiétude et sans se cacher
à l'époque tu pouvais aller dans ce
genre d'endroit et se sentir heureux
mais à la seconde où tu en sors tu es tu
savais que tu es entré dans un monde qui
ne te comprenais pas où tu n'étais pas
protégés maintenant je n'ai plus aucune
crainte je n'ai pas peur d'être rejetés
à cause de ma sexualité je peux être
fier à l'intérieur comme l'extérieur
la visibilité de la communauté
homosexuelle ne s'arrête pas au long de
l'année le lendemain tg choir seront
dans un centre commercial de la capitale
indienne le temps d'un week-end un
marché met à l'honneur les créateurs
lgbt
si l'article 377 n'avait pas été abrogée
un tel événement dans un lieu aussi
ordinaire ne serait probablement jamais
arrivé armé de son smartphone le
trentenaire partage l'événement avec ses
112 mille abonnés instagram sur les
réseaux sociaux la jeune génération met
en lumière cette communauté comme jamais
auparavant
le fait que nous ayons nos propres le
devis pour nous rassembler à la vue de
tous
cela signifie aussi qu'il faut compter
avec nous désormais personne ne peut
nous faire taire
une visibilité qui s'installe dans le
quotidien des indiens l'inclusion au
travail c'est le défi de sourds h
ramdass élu mister gay indre 2019
et si en tant qu'individu vous vous
lever et vous dit tu sais ce n'est pas
bien alors cette personne va se sentir
en sécurité
comment réagir face à un collègue
victime de discrimination comment se
comporter face à une personne faisant
son coming c'est ce qu'il enseigne
chaque mois dans cette entreprise de la
silicon valley indienne à bengalore pour
lutter contre les stéréotypes
ça aide beaucoup de personnes nous
offrons un espace sécurisé ans notamment
pour les personnes qui n'ont pas fait
leur coming out ou qui se cherche encore
il ya une prise de conscience chez les
dirigeants et chez les gens
ce genre de programme est vraiment
nécessaire
je le recommande à toutes les
entreprises
ce type d'initiative permet de briser
les tables mais les représentations
culturelles sont tenaces honnir et
réalisateur il y à 17 ans il fut l'un
des premiers à parler d'homosexualité au
cinéma ce soir il a rendez-vous dans une
librairie pour la sortie de son
autobiographie
on est envahis constamment parce est
hétéro normativité écrasante et par tout
ce qui relève de la représentation
hétérosexuels
rares sont les artistes comme lui à être
ouvertement gay surtout à bollywood
malgré quelques avancées le chemin est
encore long
la plupart du temps la représentation
qu'ils se font des personnes lgbt cui
est issu d'un point de vue très
hétéronormée comment ils veulent nous
voir comment ils nous acceptent
ils ne s'intéressent pas à la manière
dont environ réellement nos vies une
vision de la société encore très
patriarcale et conservatrice
dont les lesbiennes indiennes sont
également victimes beaucoup ne peuvent
pas vivre leur homosexualité au grand
jour et subissent de fortes pressions
sociales notamment celles du mariage
avec un homme marche à 23 ans a fui son
domicile familial il ya deux ans c'était
la seule solution pour échapper à une
union avec un inconnu imposé par ses
parents je pensais au suicide
je me demandais s'il ne fallait pas
mieux que je saute sur les rails du
métro
elle trouve refuge au sein d'une
association qui vient en aide aux
lesbiennes et aux personnes transgenres
depuis marche a fait son coming out mais
son père continuent de dépenser des
milliers de roupies auprès de prêtres
hindous pour qu'elle trouve amarrée
il dit mon nom celui de mes parents sont
venus à communauté et il fut ensuite des
prières pour que je me marie bientôt
aujourd'hui il trouvera inacceptable que
je veuille me marier avec la femme
si la constitution me le permettait je
pourrai alors leur dire regardez la loi
autorise j'ai le droit je ne fais rien
de mal
mais ce n'est pas le cas
après une première victoire il ya quatre
ans la communauté lgbt en attend
davantage le mariage pour tous est la
prochaine étape d'un long combat